the megalodon
the big boss of our ancient oceans the
king of all sharks
killer of whales if you're a fan you've
already witnessed our megalodon versus
mosasaur episode but
how would it fare against this mythical
sea creature
who would make the first move
how fast would the megalodon be
and what tricks would the kraken have up
its sleeve
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if a megalodon shark fought the kraken
according to legend the kraken was so
large that its body could be mistaken
for an
island yeah it lured ships with the
promise of a
safe landing and then snap its
mouth would close around the unfortunate
prey
swallowing the ship whole but ancient
sailors
aren't exactly a reliable source of
information so
we're going to mix legend with fact and
model our kraken on squids and octopuses
besides the kraken wouldn't have to be
as large as an
island to be a worthy opponent
okay we're off the coast of norway where
the krakens and the megalodon's
territories
overlap in one corner we have the
megalodon
this beast comes in at over 18 meters
long
three times the size of the largest
great white shark
and it's twice as fast as a great white
with a maximum speed of over five meters
a second
[Music]
the megalodon's main weapon is its rows
of enormous teeth its favorite pastime
is
snacking on whales dolphins and seals
and in the other corner we have the
kraken
this monster is even larger at 39 meters
long
three times the size of the largest
giant squid
the underside of its long tentacles are
covered in suction cups and capped with
rotating hooks
instead of teeth the kraken has a beak
on its
underside that can pierce the hardest of
shells
its favorite pastime is sinking shifts
by creating giant whirlpools
now you must decide whose team would you
be on
ok it's night the prime hunting time for
both of these ocean beasts the megalodon
would have the initial advantage sensing
the vibrations of
a giant beast up ahead stealthily
it would stalk the kraken it would
circle its prey at a distance
sizing up this formidable foe and then
it would strike
the megalodon would swim full speed at
the crack and ramming into it and
sinking its teeth into the kraken's
delicate skin
and it's quite a chop the largest
megalodon tooth is 17.8
centimeters long and it's not just
its bite that would be bad the kraken
weighing around three tons would be no
match for the 50 tons of shark that just
collided with it at high speed
but the megalodon wouldn't be able to
finish off the kraken with
just one bite so it would release the
kraken
and circle again preparing for its next
strike
but the kraken would save one trick for
the epic finale
it would vomit its digested food
muddying the surrounding water and
attracting other fish
all the different smells and vibrations
would disorient the megalodon
and what the crack and lacks in weight
it makes up for in
strength like an octopus
90 percent of its body is pure muscle
it would whip its tentacles around
catching hold of the megalodon with its
wicked hooks
the megalodon would struggle using its
body weight to try
and escape the kraken but the kraken is
too strong
and its grip would be unshakeable as its
suction cups cling on to the megalodon
the megalodon could bite into one of the
kraken's tentacles
tearing it apart but that wouldn't be
enough
the kraken would continue to wrap up the
megalodon
bringing the shark to its mouth with its
giant beak
it would bite into the monster shark
one or maybe two bites and the megalodon
would be defeated
the kraken would then take its tasty
meal
deep into the depths below oh
that was terrifying if you like this
legendary ocean fight well you should
watch a giant sea scorpion take on a
killer whale
but that's a story
for another what if
you